I'll be brief as befits my relatively
junior role in this course the what
miroslav says about or rick warren says
about hand heart head i absolutely right
and there's lots of cognitive research
to the effect that it is right the stuff
in fella named barge in the yale psych
department is doing where you ask people
their preferences about real and
concrete things and they give you
answers and then you ask them the
reasons and the reasons don't fit and
the interpretation is that the heart
rules and rules in a way that is
illogical and only only has a passing
familiarity with the conscious mind it's
a very interesting story an area the my
religious faith such as it is is more
about hand and heart than about head and
I grew up with some aversion to
abstractions about God and I was a
preacher's child and I found those
abstractions mysterious and and often
phony and they often felt like baloney
to me and and I and I think I don't know
if we sliced up all the things said
invoking the deity in public some
fraction of it would actually qualify
for that title I think 80 yeah some in
some pretty considerable portion the
vivid I this morning I thought about
what what's the most vivid religious
experience my life and it is my father
coming home and saying I'm going to have
to have a new job and we're going to
have to move sunday were baptizing a
what he said Negro family this was
nineteen forty eight
and I was frightened by that but it
formed one of the central streaks in my
life long character about values having
to do with justice and in a kind of
fundamental truth telling about the
value of human beings and all that I
think could be packaged in any of the
great religious faiths I may be mistaken
about that but I think those impulses
which I think are fundamental and
profound don't depend much on highly
abstract doctrine now the Charles Taylor
piece which I for all its wind eNOS is
really I think he's really getting it
there and I think we are in what he
calls the third aspect of secularization
the aspect where where there may be
fervent religious belief but it is
always in the consciousness of choice
about religion and other belief systems
there is a an internalized pluralism
which is probably knew probably
relatively new to the modern world it
may have been it surely existed in the
ancient world in the most sophisticated
cities of Greece or Rome but as a
worldwide phenomenon it's probably new
and it's it's important it ties into the
notion of provisional belief and the the
humility about one's own ability to know
i think is really important for me an
economist named fa hayek with a book
constitution of Liberty published nearly
50 years ago 48 years ago where he says
society is not created by some genius
it's created by the actions of millions
of people over centuries and the idea
that any one of us can
Master the whole thing is on its face
absurd and with and with that the
globalization process is in part a
learning process and the total store of
knowledge within in between societies
increases like this almost vertically so
that's seen from the point of view of
any person however clever or
well-educated the darkness exceeds the
light at an ever greater ratio the
things I really can know myself are a
small fraction of what is out there to
be known one last point the the Blair
foundation project is interesting and
very inspiring and the question I know
it's a little early to talk about this
Tony professor Blair I love I love that
title it does it does it sound funny to
you yes I thought more it sounds funny
to everyone else yeah the question of
how succession in the project the is
this thought to be something which might
last for generations that's what
everyone hopes about any project yes
well and the the question then is how do
you how do you give it allow it to
accumulate a history which will inspire
that and i would i would urge that the
that it have enough focus on practice of
practice of really hard things that that
be its dominant image in a way and i
think its capacity to inspire will be
greater that way and very great thank
you